when this was all going on and there
were delays
who wants to let me in on what the group
chat looked like between all of you
during all of this
what's happening no one knew anything
it was crazy because we were about to
the you girls went to new york right
because
we were all going to new york to depress
in april
like it was in march to release the film
in april but it was the week that
everything happened right yeah we were
like
ready to go we were in new york and we
were like
should we be at this press thing like is
this safe
or maybe we should and they're like well
who's gonna watch the film like maybe
that's not gonna be safe and
yeah and then obviously everything got
locked down and it all feels like a
distant memory now
um but yeah i think all of us were just
hounding josh we were like josh
what is going on like yeah uh it's like
he always was on like both sides of the
conversation you know
so we were always just like hounding him
and i need to know so amazing i'll start
with you on this between
your run on game of thrones and all the
delays with this
are you one of the world's greatest
secret keepers
um i want to think so i'm actually not i
feel like i'm a real blabbermouth
like if one of my family members is like
don't tell
so and so but here's the t then i'll go
and tell someone else
but i guess in my professional life i'm
a very good secret keeper
i filmed this before i filmed
the final season of game of thrones and
that
is coming you were telling us that you
were going to do a nine week shoot for a
battle i remember us having that
conversation
that came out like that finished like
over a year ago like that's
gone yeah i totally remember you telling
us like oh my god we're gonna shoot the
nine
weeks the fight sequence and we're like
wow that's gonna be amazing it is
very cool to be a mutant and everybody
i'm sure is happy with the power that
they were given
uh but does somebody else in the cast
have maybe a cooler power
that you secretly wish you had no i
i like my power i think anya's character
definitely has like the
the like prettiest like the coolest
looking powers
like she gets to like be the real like
it actually like a superhero in the
movie
but i really like danny's powers i
wouldn't trade them for anybody
else's i don't think
i would like to have my power now just
because of corona virus
because i can put poor spirit around
myself and around people so i could
protect everybody
not very mask wouldn't that be the best
we need that that would be really cool
oh you're not wearing a mask
forcefield uh aside from this people
love to nerd out do you guys
have that one sort of thing in your life
that you nerd out over it may not be
a movie like this it may be something
else but do you have that one thing that
you just go bonkers for
i during this lockdown i have been
watching
succession um and well there's a lot of
hbo shows actually like
they turned out they do pretty good
but i've been like binge watching all of
these hbo shows because before i was on
game of thrones like i didn't even know
what hbo i didn't know anything about
anything and so since
like you know having all of this free
time succession
barry they destroy you
i may destroy you yeah an absolutely
amazing yeah you guys were fantastic i
really appreciate your time uh
congratulations on everything it was
wonderful hanging out with you
thank you take it easy
you